welcome
and hello to everyone who's coming in
i'll give it a minute as people get
connected get their audio going
[Music]
hi thank you all for coming i'm paul
north
for those of you who've been at these
you'll know that this
is a series at the whitney humanities
center called the value of marx's
capital
they're the frankie lecturers and the
humanities and they are made possible by
the generosity of richard and barbara
frankie
the lecturers are intended to present
important topics in the humanities to a
wide and general audience
and we usually have had it so i
appreciate everyone who's been
sticking with us and who's come back
i'll thank again alice kaplan the
director of the whitney humanities
center
sandra malone bowles and lyanna
hereshfield crown
for organizing and audrey leak for
checking us out those of you who've been
here know
that the workshop will run with a
presentation first and then questions
i'm going to ask you to hold your
questions and you can put them in the
chat once we get to the end
that just keeps us from losing them up
the chat
once you do that we'll go through them
in the order that they get in there and
we'll open up your mics so that you can
ask your questions
if you don't want to ask the question
and you'd like me to just note that
in the chat i start
usually with a quote from the author
and scholar who's visiting us this is a
quote from chapter 7 of marx's inferno
this is a a rousing passage that gets my
republican
mind going quote the precise
institutional arrangements that will
best suit
any particular group of free and
associated laborers
will necessarily have to take into
account the particularities of their
situation
their common resources their characters
and histories and interrelations
the people best placed to know those
particularities will be those free and
associated laborers themselves
anyone who presumes to say from afar how
they ought to manage their common
affairs might rightly expect to be told
to mind their own business the solutions
to each association's problems will have
to emerge out of the context of the
problems themselves
and the institutions of freely
associated people are their own affair
provided that no one is dominated this
is a really exciting passage from marx's
inferno i'm going to turn
over the mic to my colleague paul reiter
who will
our speaker uh thank you all and thanks
everyone for
for being here tonight and thanks also
to uh
will claire roberts for for being here
will it's a real
pleasure to to introduce you and uh to
be able to interact with you
over zoom um will
uh is a is an associate professor
at a political science at mcgill
university and he is a person of
broad-ranging
interests he's worked on such topics as
bds
and political theory but his his
main work to date is the book marx's
inferno which i imagine
many of you uh know it was very widely
reviewed when it came out it was
reviewed in
jacobin by none other than david harvey
it was
reviewed also in the nation and a number
of
academic journals and uh it was
uh the winner also of the isaac and
tamara
deutscher memorial prize in in 2017.
the book makes a number of bold
arguments
um one having to do with the
uh with marx's use of dante's inferno
hence the title as a kind of structuring
template
in the book another having to do with
the idea that
capital offers a political theory um
and sometimes in some of the reviews you
you
can see that these are uh treated as
separate undertakings in in one book um
when in fact
at least in my reading they're they're
intimately related
uh connected by among other things
will's interest in in the language of
capital
and how the language of capital relates
to
the language of marx's context
and that
aspect of the book i i find uh very
exciting and
and uh i've learned a lot from it um
well
uh let me just add and closing this
introduction is also an
incredibly uh generous colleague who
has been sharing his intimate knowledge
of the french edition
of capital with us paul and me as we
pursue this edition uh project and we're
very grateful to him for that and and
glad that he's
part of the project as well and uh
and so uh yeah please uh join me in in
welcoming
uh will claire roberts to our our our
series here
um as paul likes to say at this point
there would be thunderous applause but
it's
zoom so uh we'll you can just
jump in great um
thank you paul um for that uh warm
introduction um
thanks to both of you pauls uh for
this opportunity to speak both with the
seminar students and sort of thanks to
the
the via negativa of modern catastrophe
and the technology by which we cope with
it
to this much wider audience
and beyond the specific gratitude
that i feel for this opportunity i also
do feel a much deeper dan debt to paul
and paul because they are undertaking
this
uh which is i think a true service to
the scholarly community
um bringing out a new translation new
edition of capital
the first translation into english in
nearly 50 years
and it's sorely needed i'm going to have
the pleasure of teaching the manuscript
translation
in a seminar of my own at mcgill
beginning in january
and i'm very excited and uh grateful to
be able to
uh do so um as all to sarah joined us
uh it's important to be you know to read
and re-read capital through the word
um and from beginning to end
and that brings me to the substance of
my comments for the evening
from beginning to end um
i'm going to start with a moment of
disagreement or of difference at least
something that divides me from
some of the illustrious colleagues who
have already spoken with you so far this
term
um for many of them as for mikhail
heinrich
for example this is a quote from mikhail
um marx's legacy is not a finished work
but rather a research program
and my perspective is not contradictory
but is different
i certainly do not want to deny that
capital represents an
open and ongoing research program it
certainly does
however i also think that it is
important to treat
uh volume one uh which was published by
marx
three times in 1867
again in 1872 in a revised edition and
finally in the french translation of
1872-1875
i think it's important to treat it as a
book
so what's a book um uh
as uh i teach platonic dialogues all the
time and so i know from socrates that
what is questions are very very hard to
answer but i do think we can
agree that books have certain
characteristics
books have a beginning and an end they
have
structure they have shape there's
something
finished completed done you know it's
it's sent off into the public
it's published and when it's published
it exists then as a
standalone object something to be
encountered and read as it is
in whatever context it happens to land
shortly before ben faux published his
translation of volume 1
french theory in part in reaction
against technocrats of the right and
left
in part trying to put an affirmative
face on the
out-of-control processes of power and
revolt that
swept them along declared the death of
the author
unfortunately i think what we've ended
up with instead might be the death of
the book
um take for instance the
really gruesome children's author j.k
rowling
when she wishes to indicate that one of
her major
characters in her major work is in fact
a gay man
she did not do anything so crass
were basic as include a description of
or allusion to that fact in her books
rather she just went on writing her
books however she pleased
and merely declared after the fact and
in the media
that this particular character is gay
nothing you might read in the books
could possibly tell you this
only the author's extramural declaration
makes it so and that seems to me to be
an author declaring the uh
sort of the death of her own book right
they are never finished
the words on the page are in the final
analysis uh completely irrelevant to
their interpretation
like that case is absurd obviously um
and so is the author but
the history of marxism is not as
unfamiliar as i would like
with the rowling school of textual
interpretation
the key to what marx's works
marx's published words often mean is
sometimes
supposed to be nowhere in his published
works
nowhere in his pamphlets nowhere in his
books nowhere in his articles
no published word is final uh since an
interpreter
can declare what it should mean on the
basis of something else
one of marx's letters or notebooks
something written by
another author completely
often times a current political exigency
or what the most recent economic crisis
etc i think it's important therefore to
read volume one as a book
because i think it's important to treat
it as something done
i think it's important to treat it as
something that can be deciphered
um and explained at the level of the
word
um at the level of word choice sentence
construction
concrete references the transition from
one thought to the next
it matters for my purposes that marx
never finished volumes two or three
uh he never tried to publish the
grundrissa but he published
volume one three times in two languages
and those
three versions of the book were finished
products
they have beginnings and ends and they
can be figured out
um and they can be read and interpreted
therefore i think without any reference
i'm not saying that this is the only way
that they can be read and interpreted
but they can be read and interpreted
without any reference to anything else
marx wrote because
that's what publishing a book means it
means putting something
into the hands of readers who may know
nothing else about you
and trusting that they can figure out
what's going on
so that's my the perspective that i'm
approaching the book from
now on the other hand if you do know me
from my book uh if you're familiar with
my book you might be thinking to
yourself
uh wait aren't you the guy who claims
the key to the structure of volume one
is dante's inferno
and the key to its argument is marx's
disagreement with prudone
like but fair um but
i have a couple rejoinders um first
uh i want to say something about what i
take to be the political purpose
and rhetoric of capital and then i want
to turn to its structure
and in particular to its relation to
science um
and that means in this case uh its
relationship to political economy
so david harvey gave a
series of lectures last year at the
people's forum
and they're all up on youtube in which
he sort of reprises his
famous lecture class lectures reading
capital and he starts those lectures off
by talking about the wealth of
illusions and metaphors and other
literary elements in capital
and then he says basically well yes
there's all of this wonderful literary
stuff in there
but at the center of the book is a
certain structure of argument
i think this is a tried and true
approach to reading marx it's uh
[Music]
it's shared by analytical philosophers
and radical geographers alike
and what it assumes is that capital can
be
at least analytically separated into its
argumentative structure
on the one hand and its literary
references
on the other and i've never really
shared this perspective so
another reference so in the june 17 1883
issue of la battai which was the radical
parisian newspaper that was edited by
marx's almost son-in-law prosper olivier
le cigaret
there's a little ad for a radical
workers bookstore
and it trumpets its selection of
socialist republican propaganda
and it lists alongside guests uh
catechism
socialist and our nose uh histoire
parliamentaria de la comun
balons la quintessance de socialism
it also lists the capital by karl marx
five francs
um i think that little ad is
actually uh a truer key
to understanding capital than any
hermeneutic that tries to isolate the
propositional content
and structure of marx's argument from
its literary form and references
if you say to a crowd expropriate the
expropriators
i don't think it makes a lot of sense to
try to separate out the argumentative
structure from the literary references
in that claim
in the following sense the argument
of that claim is constituted by the
illusions and metaphors of the statement
expropriation is a roman legal concept
justifying the seizure of property by
the public authorities
for the common good the redoubling of
the term
implies not only that we should seize
property
and not only that we should do so for
the common good
but that the current proprietors
also seized it from others themselves
and
i think that's the most interesting part
and that they seized it for the common
good or at least they thought they were
or could they could represent themselves
as having done so or they could
plausibly justify themselves in this way
you can explain and explicate i think
all of this
and it absolutely has an argumentative
structure
but the original statement remains
essentially
an effort to propagate a political
analysis
and course of action which simply does
not make any sense outside of its
references to roman law
and its imperative form of address
and i think that's true of capital as
well as a whole
and this is why radical booksellers
would see it as a book
of socialist republican propaganda right
reading capital as a book therefore for
me
does not mean treating it as sort of
hermetically sealed off from the world
it doesn't mean that it's locked up in
its internal relations
rather it means for me treating it as
an intervention in the world uh
referring constantly to
other books to other texts to other
discourses
and incidentally this is also why i'm a
little more bullish on the
french edition than say mikhail heinrich
is
um so uh he made a couple references to
his uh criticisms of the the french
translation when
we were uh when he was giving his talk a
couple weeks ago
i think that a lot of those reservations
hinge on
you know claims in marx's letters and
that i think are there's no reason to
doubt necessarily but that
you know marx really tried to simplify
and
popularize especially the first couple
chapters
for the french edition and i
think that there are reasons
to you know because of that i think that
you know heinrich has good reasons to
look also at the second german edition
and at the appendix to the first german
edition
but i also think that marx's persistent
efforts to popularize and simplify
capital that is to give it a form of
expression that's
suited to uptake and propagation amongst
militant proletarians
need not be thought of at least simply
as
like watering down truths that
uh you know the proper expression of
which
is exacting precise and
a bit esoteric so therefore
my emphasis on volume one status as a
book
goes hand in hand with my insistence
which i
picked up in at least in part from
terrell carver
who uh gave a talk earlier as well um
that this is a political intervention
right that
capital is an address to the workers
movement uh
and an attempt to propagate socialist
republicanism
[Music]
so um that's the the first thing i sort
of wanted to say
um on the other hand i think the
presumption that
as readers and now i want to talk more
about this uh relationship to
science and structure i think the
presumption that as readers
that we should try to separate out
marx's arguments from its literary
trappings
i think that's related to and in part
draws its strength from
another presumption a very old one
that capital is a work of science and
a critique of ideology um
a recent essay by frank ruda
that you may run into uh unpacks that
presupposition
i think it's it's a fun little essay um
but it unpacks that presupposition
with considerable originality uh by
reading marx's ideology critique as
an inheritor of plato's image of the
cave
right um and he aligns that
with uh but then also says it requires
supplementation by hegel's
science of spirit i don't think everyone
is so
extravagant uh in their elaborations on
that theme of ideology critique
but i think ruda's explorations are
entirely consistent with
a broad swath of marxist discourse
and to discuss this swath of discourse
more broadly i'm going to have to
mention dante
so one of the claims i make in
my book is that in capital marx
casts himself as a vergil to the
proletariat
by which i mean he guides the
workers through the hell of political
economy
but in the time since i've written that
and having been questioned many times
about and pushed on my use of
dante i've realized that
thinking structurally it would be more
accurate and precise
to say that virgil is to dante's inferno
as political economy is to marx's
capital
so in his inferno
basically i think one way of reading
dante's inferno is to just say
it dante is here narrating for us his
own reading of virgil's enid
uh so dante's lost and confused in the
middle of his life
he turns to virgil's poem and he finds
there
a sort of indirect path to recovering
his christian faith
and he was able to do this because
virgil showed dante basically the depths
of human depravity
he showed him human cruelty and
stupidity
and virgil claimed to know how to
navigate
those depths and there are some things
that i think
virgil claims in the aeneid or seems to
to lots of its lots of its readers
he claims that wickedness is its own
punishment
for example that virtue is its own
reward
and that nature is sufficient unto
itself
and therefore perfect these were
teachings that
virgil himself had probably picked up at
least in part
from lucretius whose deram nathura
virgil considered to be the greatest
work of human poetry
so where this is the the perverse
cruelty of dante
so where in his moral cosmos does dante
put his teacher
virgil his teacher lucretius
and all the other followers of epicurus
well he puts them deep in the bowels of
hell
right um his inferno could be
subtitled the critique of virgil um
because it shows him learning from but
also going beyond
virgil and it shows him subjecting all
of classical antiquity
uh all of the classical antiquity that
virgil epitomizes
to a damning criticism that this
uh classical antiquity and epicureanism
in particular
has no faith in or insight into the
sources
of the nature that it claims to
understand
i think that's basically the role that
political economy plays for marx
marx narrates for us in capital his own
reading
of this bourgeois science right
and he asks his readers to follow along
and just as virgil booth claims to know
the path
through hades and is yet condemned to
reside in a hill that he can't fully
comprehend
so also political economy claims to know
how the production and distribution of
wealth works
but it's also prisoner of a capitalist
mode of production that it barely
fathoms
um and if this is the right way
to think about the relationship between
political economy and capital
uh and this is for me what's at stake in
reading capital as marx's inferno
then i think several important
consequences follow
first of all capital is not
i think part of the tradition of
ideology critique
at least as that tradition is hugely
understood
in fact i would go even further i would
say it's not even part of the history of
critical theory
if we accept someone like raymond
goice's
reconstruction of that tradition as
in the claim that critical theories aim
at producing enlightenment
that is knowledge of one's true
interests
by emancipating agents from ideology
i don't think that's what capitals
trying to do at all
instead i think capital is part of
a much less appreciated tradition that
of political critiques of science
i think for marx state of the art social
science
political economy can show us the inner
connections
of the world we live in it can teach us
how this present social order hangs
together
but it cannot tell us how to create a
new world
or how to go about inhabiting that new
world
so if the guiding question of ideology
critique is
spinoza's question like why do people
fight for their slavery as if herself
as if for their salvation then i think
the the question for the critique of
science is different
it's more like something like uh what
are the forms of intelligibility
of systems of domination and how do
these forms of intelligibility
function as justifications for resisting
the emancipatory movements
of the dominated
so um simon clark i think has made a
related point something very he said
something very similar i think
he and clark wrote that marx's critique
of political economy
does not create a space for a marxist
political economy
since political economy can never do
more
than describe the alienated forms of
social existence
so i differ from clarke clark in
not finding much conceptual or political
clarity and describing social relations
in capitalism as
alienated forms of social existence
i think it's better to say that social
relations
and capitalism um insofar as they're
mediated by the market
are dominated forms of social existence
being dominated means something
particular it means
being exposed to a power that you cannot
control
a power that can interfere in your life
and upset your expectations
at any time therefore
dominated agents while they are not
forced to act in any particular way
have strong incentives to study
anticipate avoid and
cater to agents with dominating power
because domination by the market is not
domination by
particular identifiable agents
but by anonymous masters of buyers and
sellers
whose aggregate aggregate acts can ruin
me
it's no surprise i think that it is
market-based capitalist societies
that gave rise to the scientific study
of what hegel called in the philosophy
of right
um the mass relationships and mass
movements in their qualitative and
quantitative determinancy and complexity
and that's modern social sciences right
statistical sciences political economy
um
economic science
the science of political economy
according to
hegel and i think this is right it
produces
knowledge this is hegel knowledge of
this
shimmering of rationality within the
sphere of need
and higgle therefore says that it calls
it a reconciling element
within modern society
marx's critique of political economy
is supposed to i think undo this
reconciliation
by showing that the intelligibility
of movements and relations of
market-mediated society
rests on the domination of the
market-dependent producer in general
and the wage market-dependent
proletariat in particular
so that's the that's the first sort of
big conclusion that i want to
draw from that um the second conclusion
that i want to draw
and in some ways this is obvious so i
don't really need the architecture in
order to draw this conclusion but
we'll go there anyway i think marx's
authority
insofar as he has any does not arise
from any experience of exploitation or
domination
right marx is not an exploited worker
he's not drawing on experience in order
to say
look i've seen this i've done this i
this has happened to me
rather any claim to authority that he
has comes from his claim to know the
enemy
right um and
more than this i think i think we can go
beyond that and say that
i think capital is an attack on
any would-be guides and leaders of the
workers movement
who would claim authority on the basis
of experience
um and i think for this reason it's no
accident
that marxism opens up onto
the leninist question right
where does social democratic
consciousness that is the theoretical
leadership of the movement where does it
come from
but it opens up onto this question i
think not quite for the reason that
kaotsky and lennon thought
it's not it doesn't open up onto this
question because marxism
inherits and incorporates the history of
bourgeois science
right it's not that we have leadership
of the movement
because we have
all of this scientific awareness
on the contrary it's because marxism
could plausibly claim to have discovered
the limits of bourgeois science
and i i think in that vein i think
there's room for something like a
general
critical social science one that
identifies and studies
any and all forms of domination
on the model of capital but i think
that this could not be
or even contain a critique of ideology
i don't think that's the that's what's
at stake at all
so going back to goes because i think
he's very clear on this i think and so
goys claimed that the very heart of the
critical theory of society is its
criticism of ideology
their ideology is what prevents the
agents in society from correctly
perceiving their true situation
and real interests
i think this conception of the task of
critique
i mean on the one hand i think it's just
kind of in the modern world i think it's
kind of bankrupt i don't think ideology
is the barrier to emancipation
but more apropos of our topic for this
evening i
i what i is more important right now is
that i think it's
foreign to marx's capital um
i don't think that conception can draw
any basis of authority from capital
which is not and does not contain i
think a critique of ideology
um so far from thinking that the
proletariat is inhibited by ideology
from its efforts at self-emancipation
i think marx has complete faith
not only that human beings in general
could devise and
implement a global system of governance
that both protects everyone from
domination
and is democratically accountable but
also that this global system
would and could only emerge from the
struggles of the dominated
i think marx's faith in the masses was
as close as he got to dante's faith in
god
so if we don't share that faith if we
don't share that confidence then
i don't think we have any warrant to
base our pessimism
in his capital so
that's the end of my prepared remarks
and
then we can take this discussion uh
wherever people want to go
thank you well here's another moment for
applause and a lot of gasps
and wow and um
okay lots of controversial stuff i think
to talk about
thank you i think you said that i was
supposed to take uh something that
people thought about capital and
disagree with it
so i tried to try to breathe this is
where
we're valuing capital here as we speak
or
whatever you want to call it i
appreciate it
so we'll we'll open up the chat for
questions i want to encourage the
students in the seminar
to pose questions we recently finished
the book you can recall what we did that
after a lot of work so you
should at least locate the expropriation
of
expropriators and be able to
ask some questions about that maybe i'll
start with a question if you don't mind
will
so ah
i want to if you can give a little finer
distinction between what goes
and maybe even certain line of frankfurt
school
readers of marx or non-readers of marx
inheritors of an idea of marx think of
as the enlightenment
of the people burdened with a dual
consciousness or ideology
and what you're talking about the kind
of
knowledge because it still seems to be
knowledge
that the book is giving to the working
class
on one hand it seems to be that it is
steering the mass
readership away from its representation
by um metrical social science
towards something else so i understand
that but
is it still a form of knowledge and how
is that supposed to work then you
you open up this picture you take them
into hell
and then you move to
almost automatically in that section
that's something that the students
remarked on and i think is right
and it's not a it's not as you know a an
imperative
it's kind of a fatal complete the
expropriators
are expropriated as though it happens
magically it's almost the same kind of
magic
that goes or frankfurt school people
think happen when you take ideology away
at least the way it's presented so what
is the difference in
the kind of knowledge and the kind of
change that happens
in the mass from reading this book
um it's a great question or complex of
questions i guess
um so i guess
what i want to i think the classic place
where people
um locate or try to locate a
theory of ideology in
capital is in the discussion of
fetishism
and they they see in fetishism a
a sort of a false consciousness
um in which um and
and this has given birth to i mean this
gets taken in a million different
directions
um um but
i i think it's incredibly
important that marx never
calls the the fascism of the commodities
or the fetish character of the
commodities he never calls it false
uh or an illusion right um
it is um in fact the
like what you see is what you get when
you
when you see that um social relations
are relations amongst things that's
because that's right
um so um to me i think
that the the attempts to locate
something like
a a false consciousness that
um fails our
actual social experience and
that closes us off
from an awareness of our true interests
i mean i just think that's an alien
problematic to to what marx is
up to uh in the book um and that
on the on the contrary um
what he wants to do
yeah so you asked you know what do we
know from
we i mean we know we know a couple
things
on the one hand we know
we know what political economy knows
right in the sense that we know
um we know about the workings of
the market right um we know about
um how the circulation of commodities um
goes through um we know
about and so you get you know to some
extent what marx is doing in capital is
improving upon the ricardian political
economy of his time so part
of the work that he's doing is is like
really trying to reconstruct classical
political economy and give the best
version of political economy that he
possibly can
um but then we also know
that um what political economy
in some sense can't know
which is that um that the the
the value in circulation
can't possibly be grounded in the
concrete labors of the of the workers
that there can't be a there can't
be a a cycle of justice
um where everybody gets
back everything that they have put in
um so what you get is
is the blind spot of political economy
as well
um which is the blind spot both of of
um the the domination of producers by
the market
and the the blind spot of of
exploitation
um of the of the of the workers in
particular
so i so i mean
you you definitely like marx wants to
teach you something
like i don't want to deny that um you
absolutely come
out of this with with knowledge but it's
not i i
i don't think it
it is partly about it's about knowing
what the the the
breakdowns of bourgeois political
economy
are like where where does it where does
it fall apart where does it fail
thanks yeah that's a it's a big topic
and a lot of questions
but it's much clearer okay
we're ready to go to the to the chat
and forgive me if i missed you up above
so we'll start and if you got missed you
can
repost your question um i
see a question by tony
zanela can we open up the mic for tony
if you're willing to read
your question sure uh can you hear me
yes do you see any sort of direct
connections between
uh republican elements in dante and
marx's republicanism
so one example i gave was like how cato
is elevated to the guardian of the
purgatory
instead of being consigned to hell so
that was that's it
uh that i mean this is not a question
that i've actually explored i don't know
i
like my my my feeling about
dante is that dante doesn't care about
uh freedom especially
um uh like
dante cares about faith uh and truth
uh and beauty and and like
freedom is not a positive uh value
necessarily for
for dante i think so uh yeah i mean i so
i haven't i haven't looked at this um i
uh i think what you point out is
interesting the elevation of cato that
that is interesting
um but of course dante's dante's a
hardcore monarchist
um and in fact you know in his uh
in his book on monarchy uh you know
proposes a
a global monarchy you know a global
empire
that would uh that would have a
terrestrial
and a a spiritual um side
so um i yeah i i'm open to
i like i love reading dante and i love
um like thinking about all of the crazy
stuff that dante's up to because dante
is absolutely
a uh i mean he's a he's a
uh candy and very intelligent political
operative as well
as uh as well as just being a a great
poet
um um but i had like i said i haven't i
haven't thought more about this
thank you tony okay now we have a
question from sam
samur or samode can we open up
sam's mic hi
hi welcome hello um i got at the end of
your
of your talk i got a little lost on the
on the bridge between
um on the one hand that you know
if you're you can't claim authority for
leading the dominated masses
via your experience is dominated
to um
marx's absolute face in the dominated in
general to be the
force of transformation so i was
wondering if you could just clarify
the length there yeah
fair enough it was less of a bridge than
like a hail mary pass or something like
that
so uh um
so i guess what i wanna just what i
wanted to
at least gesture to are a couple
different
things so on the one hand
um the
the theoretical clarification
that the workers and movement
needed mark's thought um
was this sort of
negative theory right in the sense that
it's a it's a what the theory
that they need is a
i mean they do need an account uh they
do need political economy
they do need to understand political
economy
but they also need to see they as i said
they need to see the
the limits of political economy
and up to that point uh up to the point
of
uh capital marx thought that you know
only prudone had
really even tried to talk about
political economy
in an intelligent way or taking it
seriously at all
and all i did was was um you know
produce a bunch of
uh you know you know unfortunately
very smithian uh peons to
you know the the beauty of change of
of commodities so um
so on the one hand marx thinks that
the the theoretical leadership that the
the workers movement needs
is this clarification of the stakes of
political economy and
and a proper sort of destruction
of political economy as a science
um on the other hand
they uh like that that sets aside the
question of political leadership
right political leadership that
political leadership may well come from
experience but um
but the theoretical clarification is not
going to come from
any sort of experience of being
exploited um it's not going to come from
any sort of
experience of being cheated in uh
exchange
or from you know having to you know pay
a high interest rate or something like
that
like that's not that doesn't clarify
the situation of the proletariat
it doesn't clarify how um capitalism
works or hangs together
um it doesn't and it doesn't point to
the limits
of of the capitalist mode of production
at all
um so so that's the thing i guess i want
to
i want to separate out the sort of
theoretical
question the theoretical leadership um
and the political leadership question
and those for marx those are just going
to be very separate things
um i think that's the that's the upshot
thanks that was really helpful great
thanks yeah i don't know how you feel
about this but i feel like
there hasn't been a satisfactory
question answered to the question what
marx thought the book would do
you know there's that story that zizek
likes to quote which is
when la commune was announced mark said
well how could they do that i haven't
finished the book yet
so he obviously he had some sense this
book was going to do something almost
immediately
and you're approaching that i think
that's a really um
important question and i myself totally
agree that it's not
to expose a secret only or to blow off
the illusion
as though that would be enough
i want to
[Music]
okay
i'm picking through the questions
because i want to get ones that are that
are
um really related to the talk first
okay how about we go to sumath gopinath
can we open sumath's mic
sure it's i wasn't really um
making uh you know posing a question but
just um
saying that i i when you were speaking
uh i thought of
balibar's argument in the philosophy of
marx that ideology
is really a theory of this of the state
it came from an earlier period of marx's
work
and that fetishism is a theory of the
market and that these things are not
equivalent
um maybe the question would be what do
you think of that argument
um how do those things relate there's
certainly a lot of ideological [ __ ]
in the tradition of political economy
that can be unpacked and marx is very
good at skewering that and so um
i don't know i am i go back and forth on
this question myself but
i'd love to hear your thoughts on that
yeah i mean i'm not um i mean it's a
great question
so and it's definitely a question uh so
uh
i i
that the little bally bar book was was
very
uh important for me at one point um and
i
would probably need to go back to it
with fresh eyes now
um and see what i think of it now um i
think
that general division of
labor between ideology and and
um and fetishism
um is right but
i and i'm pretty skeptical that you can
get much of a theory of ideology out of
marx at paul
um even in the early marks i mean you
you have a
few scattered comments about ideology
hither and jan and you don't you don't
really get anything
um like um an attempt
even to systematize them or anything
like that
so my my
inclination is to say that
ballybar is definitely on to something
the
the notion of ideology as the
ideas of the ruling class does accord
i think with um with marx's
earlier sort of concerns where
he was much more into the model
of the french revolution and just kind
of pushing the french revolution through
um to another level in germany and
thinking that it would it would you know
you just have to keep pushing the rock
further and further
um and in that in that context
that ideology seems like
a yeah something like a
um a public
um discourse of legitimacy
that um and set of categories for
thinking about politics um that
um emanate pretty straightforwardly from
the official mouthpieces
of the of the state um um
i mean i think it's ironic because
marx was much more of a habermassian in
1842
um than than he was later on right
i mean marx spent a long while
trying to basically bootstrap germany
into freedom um via the creation of
a public sphere um you know just on the
back of you know
heroic journalists who wouldn't be
silenced and that it took him a while to
to leave that uh sort of
set of concerns and strategies
uh behind
that's great that was kind of political
well it's just going to say political
defeat
of the 1848 revolutions probably has
something to do with
yes and political defeat preceded
theoretical defeat right in the sense
that like i mean the political defeat of
the
in the political fee defeat of the
uh rhineston zeitung the original one um
like definitely caused something of
a break in how marx thought about
politics
um that's when he just you know
discovers the proletariat that's when he
begins to put his hopes
um in the excluded in the dominated
rather than
in the enlightened um but
um but i do think there are nuts there
are hangovers
theoretical hangovers of of that um
political defeat that last for much
longer and and absolutely
the same is true of the defeat in 1848.
thank you so much thank you for your
question we'll go to a kind of a
technical question
can we open up gabby nair
gabby are you willing to read yeah of
course
um yeah so what hey um what do you make
of the claim from arthur smith
royten murray and the rest of the ismt
crowd
that marx is doing systematic dialectics
and how do how do you feel that this
relates to your claims
regarding domination
yeah so um
i
i spent a while as a systematic
dialectician
um around 2005 i was
very into this um and and and absolutely
i think
um basically
i think that entire group are engaged in
a process
of of attempting to theoretically
reconstruct
um the marx's conception
of capitalism um
as a a you know
a dialectically interrelated um
whole i mean basically
to take um you know to say that
along the lines that hegel's conception
of
absolute knowing is to historicize that
and to say
that's correct for
the the structure of capital as such
um and and that's that
i so i don't i i mean i feel like there
are too many mediations between that and
the claims that i'm making to
straightforwardly say what i think the
the connection is there
because in part um
murray and rutin and arthur like they
have a
different problematic than me they're
treating marx as
a uh as a
as a a research program um although
more along you know more hegelian uh
in its character than uh than
someone like uh heinrich um
but and i and i'm not
like i think that's valuable i think
that's that can
like i've learned a great deal about
marx's texts from those guys
but i
it it always seems to me to be a
fundamentally
um you know fighting still fighting off
the the riccardians the riccardian
marxists
um still doing that sort of thing and
and
like that's all great and i'm totally on
their side on that fight but
it's it's just not i don't think it has
an immediate relationship to
anything like the political payoff
or the the the political
uh intervention of of capital and so i'm
not i'm not i'm not really sure
and you can see that in the bracketing
of the historical material when they
when they try to reconstruct capital
along those lines i think
okay um paul's system has apparently
crashed so i'm jumping in to moderate
for a bit while he reboots
um it seems as though there's really a
lot of interest in this
understandably and this interest about
marx and ideology
um and what sort of critique uh
is is being developed uh in in capital
and so let's let's continue to discuss
that for for a bit
um there are a number of questions on it
uh patrick
coppola um would you would you like to
read your question
can we unmute patrick if not
please yeah i think
yeah i think this isn't really a
question either i think just from the
way that i'm approaching marx and like
being open to the way that other people
approach marx
i i'm unclear on what you're trying to
say about
how critique functions in marx because
of what
i think that means i agree
that um if like i understand
what you're saying by like a political
critique of science
um it's probably better characterized
than that
by i forget what you contrasted that
against like
the producing and lighting then and then
shutting off
ideology um but i've i've always linked
critique
to like this
like thing that happens
uh beginning with kant that i see
um because i'm approaching marx more
from
like a philosophical background uh
where like like a proper duty gets
like centered in philosophical method
um so yeah and i would i would agree
that i've really paid attention to
like marx's the popularization of marx's
language like the language
in the grand greece and a contribution
to political economy um
you know he's he's talking about all
like
universal this particular that like
uh like like i don't know like every
other category it seems
to you know be i forget if the language
is like that in capital
but and and alienation is still a
category used in
in those texts too um
so yeah i don't i don't know if what i'm
saying is clear sorry
uh well i i you raised a few issues so i
i don't know that i'll get to all of
them but i do think the connection to
i you know this the connection to the
history of critique and the way the
different ways in which
um critique gets used to entitle
different projects i mean i think that's
an interesting
and a storied question one that i
wouldn't be able to
do great justice to but i do think
there's a fairly straightforward way in
which
um i think the critique of political
economy is a critique in a sense that
kant could recognize which is that um
you know part of what a critique you
know what a critique what the critical
pure reason does
is it it what it does is it finds the
proper domain
of pure reason um that is it defines it
right it it it finds the places where
the limits beyond
which if it goes it produces
monsters right um so uh in some
important sense that's what marx is
doing as well with uh the critical
political economy and that he's
he's trying to define political economy
um and that means to delimit it right to
find its limits
to find the the the points beyond which
it cannot go
um and um and in that sense to
relativize it to to locate it in the
the sphere of of history
um and and knowledge so i
i think that's fairly i think you can
say that and i don't think that's
super controversial um
yeah i'll stop there
okay alex uh
locacio who is michael
mikhail heinrichs a really excellent
translator england english translator
has a couple of questions and um
let's uh give him a chance to
to ask uh one of them they're both
interesting questions but
um we have a number to get to so alex
please please pick one of your questions
and
ask it can we unmute him
alex i don't know how to abolish the
value form i'm sorry
i assume that takes care of the other
question
um oh sorry i just went to the bathroom
site
came late um yeah i wanted you to expand
on your
um on your point that you've made in
previous articles
about marx being closer to
the marginal revolution in economics
than classical political economy
um in light of what uh misha said a few
weeks ago about um
uh you know the speculation that um
if marx had been confronted with the
marginalist revolution
um that he probably would have had great
respect for example for
um its attempts at uh mathematical
formalization
so i think the only thing that i've
committed myself to in print
uh is that i think of marx as much
closer to the austrians in general
but not as i uh not necessarily to
marginalism as such so and by that
i really mean that i think um and this
comes out already in the book it's not
going to be a big
a big shock to anybody but i i think
that
um that in particular
hayek's understanding of a market as an
information
um sharing
mechanism as a as a um
a place where you learn about
society um and to
and thinking of prices as signals
i think that that is something that is
very uh it's present in in
uh germ um in marx's discussion of
fetishism
um so that's that's the sort of thing
that i'm thinking about i
agree with you that i think marx
i mean marx was even you know
undertaking some of the
the mathematical studies to in order to
act like he had he had encountered a
couple of the early um articles
of the marginal revolution as i recall
um and
and he was he like it's something that
he would have
you know had he been healthy i'm sure he
would have taken
um to study um but i i think the
question
of you know
getting away from the biographical like
to
like what would a confrontation between
marx's critique of political economy
and marginal utility theory what would
that look like
i think that's a very hard question to
answer i think you know obviously
you know simon clark has has taken us
taken a stab at that
um which which i think is is a very
admirable
um attempt in many regards um
but um that's what i would say
okay um thank you for that
um we have a question uh
about the russian translation maybe uh
switching things up a little bit and
the question is um
i'm i i'm reading a message from paul
saying that his chat is now blank he's
back but his chat is blank so
um this question um came from
uh sabo and the uh
the question is i'm gonna i'm gonna just
uh unless i didn't i didn't i don't see
zabo in the chat at this point so i'll
i'll just read it
um which is the question is that
uh the uh the russian translation
um is important marx
thought highly of it and so
why bring the french translation
so much into play um and not
give the same kind of attention i'm
extrapolating a little bit
to the to the russian translation and
well i know you've thought a lot about
the french translation i mentioned that
in the introduction i mean the obvious
answer i suppose
is that marx basically did much of a
french translation himself
and so you know there are parts of it
that function
essentially as commentary on on his work
um he also as we know had a somewhat low
opinion of the
french intellectually um
maybe i mean he you know in his in his
exchange with
with uh engels of well-known exchange
about the french
translation he you know he recycles some
old german
tropes about french culture and its
strengths and its weaknesses and uh
suggests there that he thinks that they
need some help um in understanding
capital and so that
he's going to do some translating that's
a mix really of translation and
self-commentary
so um in any case what right what what
are your thoughts on this
now it's i mean it's a good question so
i part of this comes down to
like what's your sense of marks as a
person and how do you read his letters
uh for example um so some of these um
some of these letters about the
i certainly marx was thrilled to have
a russian translation coming out
and he was yeah he was very happy with
that
i think that
some of his like i i don't talk about it
or i don't i don't spend a lot of work
on it precisely for the reason that you
mentioned paul which is just that
like he had such a direct hand um
in the in the french translation he did
an immense amount of revising and
re-translating
um that um so i i think that's
important to to mention um and i think
it makes
it i think it makes the french
translation
much more i mean and you know at that
point you know marx's
i mean mark's learned russian um
absolutely and mark's
um but but marx had known french for
decades and had written in french and
had worked in french
um and i think his um sense
of what was going on in the french
translation would have been just as good
as his sense of what was going on in the
in the german original edition
and i think that that i think that
matters i think that the two german
editions and the french edition
like stand together as the
the ones that marks that i think we can
attribute to marx himself
whereas the russian translation has to
have um just us a bit more distance from
from marx's own hand but that's that's
all
i would say that you know any any good
translation is going to help you
um is going to be an interesting uh
fruitful
take on the work um but the question is
from a kind of like philological
perspective you know
um which do you want to to use to help
to cl
help clarify certain terms or thinking
in
in that way about bringing the french
tradition and that's you know long been
a
uh uh an aim of
of translators of capital and one of the
things that falks
has taken a lot of heat for is not
making good on his commitment
to integrating the uh the french
tradition uh the french edition excuse
me
uh in into his uh translation either
citing uh moments where
uh the french tradition the french what
i keep saying tradition when i mean
edition excuse me the french edition is
quite uh is quite different and
it does again function sort of as as
commentary
um or just not taking it into account
mainly when he
when he translated the text and uh
there's a lot there's an interesting
history if i may
continue in this vein for a moment um
among marx translators uh of not doing
what they say they're going to do
um to an extent it goes back to engels
if you read his
uh long epistolary statements about what
should be done
in a marx translation and then you look
at the addition of capital that he
basically oversaw
you know you see some pretty striking
disparities but um i
am going to move on now to another
question on
i'm gaining rapidly a greater and
greater appreciation for paul north whom
i
already appreciated immensely um
now his ability to to do this moderation
on the fly
so um philip
uh bolstetter i don't know it's a german
name
if you pronounce it with a german
pronunciation or it's wallsteader or
volsteader
in any case um philip would you like to
read your question can we unmute philip
please uh sure you can pronounce it
either way if you like
um the question really is
how people have taken both quote
economics or true economics
and a critique of political account
economy which is the critique of the
categories of
bourgeois economy and i'm wondering how
one can avoid mixing them up and
globbing together i know
when uh will is talking about marx is
close to the austrians and so forth i'm
sort of trying to think
uh it's obvious that there are different
levels in the text particularly between
1 and volume 3 and all the all the
attempts at mathematics
at the time but it leads to a larger
question of how does one sink
uh the critique of political economy and
the categories which is utterly valid
still
and tells us more about the roots of how
capitalism operates
than any other social theory of
capitalism
and uh what can be salvageable from a
discipline that's
called economics at the moment
so um i don't know if that's coherent at
all but
uh that would be my question
i think one of the one of the the big
questions and this is this is sort of
i mean it was raised by alex's question
about
um marginalism but it goes beyond that
um as well
but i think there is a there is a real
question about whether
you know to what extent would um a
critique of economics
uh a critique of contemporary economics
if mark's
a marx-like project were to get off the
ground today
um what would it have to look like you
know um
does i mean there was certainly a long
there's a long tradition of marxists
trying to
sort of um
shoehorn later developments in economics
um into
mixes critique and to basically find
ways of you know
building a little a little shanty off
the side
and and putting any new economics in
there
and i think it's always a valid question
to ask you know is that
is that actually a legitimate uh
procedure
um anymore um i mean i think one of the
like one of the dangers of of marx's
procedure
um is that like the political
critique of science can be done well and
it can be done
badly um and um certainly
i think that there are plenty
of people on both
on the left and in particular
who you know from a marxist background
who
are um you know to
dismissive of contemporary
um social science work um
like in the name of historical
concreteness
um or in the name of
um you know following the movement um or
things like that
i i think it's it's at least a you know
uh i think it's always a live question
and a legitimate
uh one to ask you know do we have
do we have a critique of contemporary um
social sciences that matches
the critique of political economy and uh
it's not obvious to me that we do
like writer i'm gonna let you continue
to ask questions because
having got kicked out my chat got
totally evacuated but
there was a question that got reposted
that was earlier and i missed
so maybe we could just ask open up the
mic of scott rittner
to not skip him again
can we open scott's mic
god are you there i am here
thank you thanks will so much for your
talk um
i i was wondering you mentioned
right at the end of your talk um a
question a
comment about um
i'm sorry scott i hate to say this but i
i've been interrupted on my end for just
one second can i can i just take a pause
sure can you take that song
the thing that we all hide when we go
into the institution
is the all the things that goes beyond
behind all of our work all of our family
obligations exactly here we go
that's right that's right real
conditions of our intellectual
production
we're no longer
yeah is that the famous outgoing
seven-year-old it's the
very famous seven-year-old that's right
um
thanks uh i was you mentioned just at
the very end of your talking it was
almost
kind of a throwaway comment but i i have
to ask about it
um that you find no basis for
pessimism in capital
but i want to challenge you on that a
little bit right
to ask if marx's analysis especially in
his more historical chapters is correct
wouldn't it require sort of concerted
pessimistic
action to affect change in the world
rather than
optimistic philosophical interpretation
um
[Music]
it's mystic action i guess yeah i'm not
sure
um
i'm not sure let me just i'll just try
to clarify what i meant by pessimism
and then i you can tell me whether or
not that um
like runs up against what you were
trying to say
um which is so i guess i like
it's no surprise to me that 20th century
um critical theorists
would be extremely pessimistic they
would be pessimistic
on the basis of real historical
experience they would be pessimistic on
the basis
not only of the failure of the
revolution in germany
not only on the basis of the experience
of nazism
um and fascism um not only on the
experience of the
the you know the the
failures of the dreams of what uh the
soviet revolution would
deliver um that there were many many
many
uh reasons to be pessimistic um in
1930 in 1940 in 1950 in 1960
um so it's no it's no surprise that that
folks would be pessimistic i think it is
i think it's an interesting question to
ask
whether um
[Music]
i i mean i guess it's an
interesting question to ask
whether that pessimism
that justifiable pessimism that
reasonable pessimism is a
is then a retroactive
um criticism of marx for his lack of
pessimism
or whether
is a um in part
a result of the expectations
of revolution changing
between 19 between 18 70-ish
um and and 1930-ish
um i and i i
and my suspicion is that to some extent
it's both
um i think um that
i think that the experience already of
the
commune um ought to and it did it gave
lots of people
uh you know good basis for you know much
more pessimistic um
uh accounts of what
the possibilities for um working-class
um revolution were in um
in europe and how quickly things were
going to go
as well as you know and that doesn't
even take into account
you know experiences in britain and so
forth so i
i yeah i guess i'm i it's there's a
that's
there's just a huge field um
exploration um and and questioning there
i don't think that
political action um is necessarily
allied
with uh pessimism nor do i think that
theory is necessarily allied with
optimism
um so i guess that's part of the reason
for my hesitation about the question
yeah thanks i i think that you and i are
on the same page at least in the the
first part of your answer i didn't mean
to imply that
theory is aligned with optimism um
someone in the chat you know
mentioned that adorno had entered the
room but uh
in any case um uh
yeah i i think that we we largely agree
upon that i guess my question
more was about thinking about like the
idea
um within perhaps the the
section on so-called primitive
accumulation right the continuation of
primitive accumulation or so-called
primitive accumulation
even after the sort of taking hold of
capital as
um an international uh system of
totality etc right and the
the sort of struggles against that which
may or may not turn out the way we
desire them to
um i think is is more along the
lines of what i was thinking in terms of
pessimism but i think
i think you and i are more or less on
the same page thank you
okay crazy
uh well uh i'll read it for him
um what are what are important
differences between marx's thought and
that of republicanism
even in its most radical forms i'm
pushing you intentionally to show us
what is at stake if we don't go
in the republican direction good to see
you will so
i guess you know
only from online you know the unreal
world
so um it's um it's a good question i
mean i think
the the the the line of demarcation i
guess there are two lines of demarcation
that i would
um draw between marx and you know
the republican tradition broadly
construed
the first i think is marx's um
understanding of fetishism i just think
i think his understanding of
um the impersonal domination of the
market is something that is
you know a complete conceptual
innovation within the
the field of republican theory and
and it really does um scramble
uh some of the the terms of
republicanism
because republicanism uh historically
and contemporarily is
is worried about the the
the lord that you can see um not about
the one you can't
um and so the the the like
the the institutions of republicanism
are all
built with the around the idea of
protecting um
people from um from personal
um domination and that means personal
dependency to some extent right um
and so they um and that is the other
side the other side is that
without that analysis
of the market as dominating
it's really hard to universalize
republicanism as a theory of
of equal liberty for all
because the the liberty that was
traditionally conceived of by
republicans
as non-domination as as freedom from
um the arbitrary will of another really
hinged on
having a place to go
to be um independent having a private
sphere to retreat into
that would give you an independent basis
in the world
right and so you get something like this
in a rent right you get
you get an attempt to uh update
um republicanism for um
contemporary world and what that really
amounts to is a
a generation and refusal of
of society and a real failure to grapple
with the market
so i think when you when you bring the
market in and you try to understand the
market as itself a form of domination
then that
i mean it really causes havoc um for
a lot of the other categories of other
republicans
i mean i think that means that
the political institutions of marxian
communism you know they
clearly have republican um
inspiration um um
and and that's true you know you get it
in lenin too whatever it just rolls on
down right like you gets
you know the the you know arming the
people
um and and large deliberative assemblies
uh
and recall of legislators right like
these these are pretty
classic things but i i
i think it is true that that is in some
sense a failure
of um of
marxists to really grapple with how much
the
theoretical innovation and what sort of
impacts that would have
on on the need for new political
institutions
and and i think i think that's just an
unsolved
unsolved problem in the history of
marxism
okay we're i'm going to wind things down
now and so
uh here is uh one of the final questions
this question is
is this buzz about this question in the
chat um
this is from raphael uh
uh uh sorry i'm i'm
i'm so that's that that one nuts uh
badly um but raphael would you like to
read your question please
yeah absolutely um will first of all
thank you for taking the time to join us
this is a
great conversation um i wanted to post
this question of coming back to what you
mentioned about the idea of critical
social science
or critical social science as an
emancipatory project
and to what extent is that related to
the critique of the state that marx
intended to make a volume of capital
or dedicated volume of capital too but
um never got around to doing it
and um i think in the sense that um so
much of the later history of marxist
theory and practice can be understood as
a
as a way of trying to fill in those
those gaps or this those lacunae of what
marx left unsaid about uh political
power
and and how to approach it that um i
think
um what does this omission itself tell
us about the relationship between state
power and political economy
right that's a great question raphael um
so
i mean first to marx's intentions i mean
mark's intended this marx intended that
marx intended everything
uh like um he he made plans for
every eventuality um and and i think
that um i think a lot of his plans were
pretty
cheap right they were like oh i'm really
interested in this
i'm going to write it down um as
something i want to tackle at some point
or another
i mean my own my own sense from having
um you know tried to work through all of
this is that
that the closest that marx actually gets
is the section on on primitive
accumulation um at the end of capital
um and that that um
that attempt to think through the state
as um you know what i call the you know
the
violent uh and armed servant of capital
um i think is a
i think there's a lot of potential in
that
conception of the state as dependent
on capital accumulation um and
as um you know attempting to
create the conditions for capital
accumulation i think that that
i i think that has promise but it's
only it's just the it's just a hint
of of what uh of the work that would
need to be done
um and and trying to bring
um you know the sort of
traditional conception
of the state as you know armed
bands of men right um trying to bring
the the treatment of the repressive
straight apparatuses
into a discussion of
the the reliance of the state on
um debt financing and the reliance of
the state on
tax financing and the
the the rough um
interactions between
the armed apparatuses of the state and
the the the financial dependence of the
state on capital accumulation
um that's all that is is i mean it's
just a
blank spot for for an immense amount of
work
um to be done that that mark certainly
did not do for us
thank you yeah this does seem like a
good moment
to pause paul
so we're we're going to thank professor
roberts for his talk and his immensely
generous
gift of his time and intelligence and
conversation
so thank you again a moment of great
applause you can't hear it but it's
going on
you can see it we thank you we're trying
to think through this book and you
really
pushed us hard so thank you so much
i don't thank you all for coming
[Music]
i don't usually give a plug for the next
talk but it happens to be tomorrow
so we have a doubleheader this week if
you want to hear karen
on a question of
human being in marx you can tune back in
tomorrow night at six
we also have a talk next week i believe
as well so we're
piling these on thank you all for
attending and we'll let you go now
until the next time thanks